brand: Like it. So
brand: breast, i'll tell you.
brand: Go to the
brand: where you
brand: by six.
brand: Good!
brand: That's one,
brand: three years
brand: for two,
brand: that dashboard
brand: it's up.
brand: That's right.
brand: That it
brand: Seventy six
brand: because it
Kristen: Hi, Brandon! Hey? How are you?
Kristen: Good! How are you?
brand: Oh, there you are,
Kristen: bye!
Kristen: He's trying to get set up a bit.
Kristen: Um,
Kristen: This is the first user interview I've done,
Kristen: really. Ah, welcome. Thank you.
Kristen: I'm excited. I like your plant behavior.
Kristen: Thank you. It's pretty big.
Kristen: I have a better way for that when it comes to plants.
Kristen: Yeah, I do have some. Yeah, I can see. I can see some in your window
behind me. Yeah, right.
Kristen: That's awesome. I used to have a huge monstera plant right there, but it wasn't getting enough sun, and it's
Kristen: sort of So yeah,
Kristen: had to move it,
Kristen: not doing great. And the white walls are good for it, too, because it gets a reflection of the light.
Yeah, Yeah, Exactly.
Kristen: Um!
Kristen: Did Kate give you like a rundown of what we have to do?
Kristen: I don't know that that yet.
Kristen: No, Ok. Ok. So I think we're going to just be testing fables, actual website.
Kristen: I'm making a video about that.
brand: It's pretty straightforward.
Kristen: Yeah, Yeah. And you've done like all of these like user
Kristen: interview like clip,
Kristen: like, you know. But yeah, okay, okay, Cool
Kristen: the good quality clips. Yeah, I've I've done user, interviews before in more of like a ux testing kind of thing, except like not so much about accessibility testing. So it that usually ended up being just kind of like a two hour.
Kristen: We're just going to go through the entire thing, and then I have to add it out little tiny clips of like a two-hour meeting.
Kristen: Fifteen years.
Kristen: Yeah, Yeah, It's like editing two hours down to a five-minute clip. That the client wants
Kristen: little time-consuming.
Kristen: Okay,
Kristen: So I guess this is recording already. So
Kristen: welcome to the team. Anyway.
Kristen: Thank you. Yeah, I've been. I've been making some videos for about a month, I think.
Kristen: But just a
Kristen: doing like my own kind of stuff like marking out files, and
Kristen: i'm doing a few other things. But
Kristen: have have you worked for fable for a long time?
brand: It's it.
brand: Um
Kristen: a little over twelve years
um
brand: in January of trade by
Kristen: Oh, that's awesome.
brand: Yes,
Kristen: their time.
Kristen: Um! Do you want to share your screen? And
Kristen: yes, it's.
brand: I'm just saying, Wake up we go to sleep a lot. So that's just the
brand: where's it?
brand: Press out. Sarah
brand: Bells died.
brand: One, two,
brand: get the same
brand: uh this is the um
brand: the last page I was out there with with cable. Let me go back to the dashboard.
Kristen: Yeah,
brand: wake up
brand: that dashboard
brand: kevin
brand: click, cancel!
brand: That's it!
brand: Click dashboard.
brand: She's, too.
brand: He's asleep.
brand: Yes,
Kristen: okay, I think for this demo. We were going to be testing like fables, actual website like not.
Kristen: But I I could be wrong. So let me just double check.
brand: Yeah, I might have bed differently. They're provided for me.
Kristen: Okay,
just let me just message Kate, because i'm not
one hundred percent. Sure, that's what I wrote down. But
Kristen M: my email here Sorry. I'm: feeling a little disorganized
brand: every second. I prepared just the case.
Kristen: What are you waiting for?
brand: We can.
brand: It's like a progress.
brand: It's like variable alternative
brand: pitcher,
brand: about seven
brand: to it to
brand: cancer.
brand: That's great.
brand: That's good.
brand: Seven, two, two.
brand: I'll do that
brand: killed him.
brand: That's right. There,
brand: You, sir.
brand: Press, enter
brand: open second tip,
brand: go this way.
Oh, okay, I guess it's a difference.
brand: Yeah, there's a lot more jet, though. Um
brand: tabs there at this page.
Kristen: Yeah, Okay, yeah, right. Okay. I remember. Yeah, this is what we're supposed to be doing. Um, I think we have to go through the drop-down menus and then also filling out the contact. Forum.
Kristen: Um, Yeah, I don't know how long these videos have to be, but
brand: it's scheduled for hours. So we got to play a type
Kristen: here.
Kristen: Okay. So all the notes that are done Yesterday, when I was talking with you, were.
Kristen: So explain how your assistant of tech works. And how do you navigate navigating through menu options
Kristen: and drop down menus?
Kristen: Yeah.
Kristen: So i'm using dragon's, actually speaking version Fifteen.
brand: Yeah. Excuse me, that's a breakthrough.
brand: Yeah, there's a good day as a chrome browser with those Ted
brand: and um
brand: I that grade for those eleven, because it
brand: i'm having some shovel with with with this Levin.
brand: The last three is a week before,
brand: so everything we're getting back to over there.
brand: Um,
brand: i've been using jacket for about twenty-five years.
brand: So it's like a second day Tv.
brand: Ah,
brand: yeah, I love it
brand: you'll see how it works. If I already how much
brand: I it's the best written stuff. And
brand: oh,
Kristen: when I can get to a link, my careers is even there. It takes less time like if I just say, click products. I'm gonna try a bit.
brand: Well, you'll see.
Kristen: Yeah,
brand: you're going to try that first.
Kristen: Sure. Yeah,
Kristen: Wake up,
brand: clip products,
brand: Go to sleep
brand: now. Is there a particular link over your chip or through?
Kristen: No, I don't think so. I guess just um.
Kristen: So, maybe like, if if the click and then the product product, whatever the link name is. If that works
brand: quicker,
brand: click, table, upscale,
brand: go to sleep and you expected to. That's a
brand: wake up,
brand: clip products
brand: click accessible Us. Ability to scale
brand: click products
brand: like fable and gauge,
brand: click, table engage
brand: It's like community
brand: quit testers,
brand: go to sleep.
Kristen: What was the other one contact. Yeah, just going through the contact form,
Kristen: and then maybe we can um
Kristen: like show the most grid, and maybe explain a bit more about that
brand: wake up,
Kristen: click, cut touch
brand: like first thing,
brand: Jeff.
brand: There,
brand: there's
brand: get the same.
brand: So yeah, it's very accessible to go to each one, each field with just a tampa, or I could have,
Kristen: he said. I don't feel which I do. I do, because that's cheap.
Kristen: But yeah, so far, everything is very, very accessible. It's like one hundred percent.
Kristen: How would you access the drop-down like the fable where it says, I want to learn more about on the
Kristen: the shift tab
brand: where I said to
brand: moved out too.
brand: Go to sleep
just as I expected. You were great.
Kristen: Thanks. So far, so good
brand: it is. It just is
brand: to get on the highlight. What I just say, Press enter
brand: it's like Use your keyboard, you know. Pretty much the same can be answers, or you,
brand: as it. Keep ever be
Kristen: nice.
Kristen: That's good. I'm glad that i'm not surprised that it wasn't accessible. But you know. So it's approved a lot since it
Kristen: that's good. Yeah, i'm. Sure, they've gotten a lot of user feedback from
Kristen: um. I just have a little trouble with the
brand: the logged in part of
brand: like we're going to bite
brand: my dashboard,
brand: and
brand: it's what they get set to be back a few seconds.
brand: I don't know if I could show you. Or
Kristen: yeah, yeah, sure. Me i'd love to know I had to go back to what, though.
Wake up,
Kristen: open every wrist, tab,
brand: go to sleep
brand: also. I don't know how you get to my
brand: the jet there, where my name is up at the core?
brand: Um! Whether it's or what?
brand: Because when I say click bread, the uh
it will go. My chrome browser
brand: um use your profile
Kristen: so I can't say that I don't know what other
Kristen: i'll be it to you. I'll make sure I show lakes. It's you. It does
Kristen: wake up,
brand: click, show legs
brand: show links
brand: two, six.
brand: It's like log out.
brand: Click! It! Did you
brand: go to sleep? Here it is. See, every time I do that it's an email is required with the emails in there. So I did it the second time I do it. It works the second time.
Kristen: Oh, that's so weird.
brand: He's
brand: presenter.
Kristen: It's It's It's it.
Yeah, So that that's all about. Um,
Kristen: yeah, I have no idea that's interesting.
Kristen: But then I could just say, long day that it goes. Wake up!
brand: Thank you.
brand: It's like a good
brand: go to sleep for that to work you there your first day.
Kristen: I'm going to be the tab.
It's a
brand: it's like a good
brand: six largest
brand: you to sleep
brand: there, you
brand: that's that's like which I have with it.
brand: I don't know. Maybe you do it. The other website, though.
Kristen: Yeah. Oh, that's interesting to know about, though
Kristen: I wonder why it does that.
Kristen: It might have to do with the O. Phil.
Kristen: Yeah,
Kristen: for instance.
Still learning more about like the like coding and website side of all of this. So
Kristen: it was like that. It's that Rosen
where I was in college.
Kristen: Yeah. Me, too.
Kristen: Yeah. My partner took a web development boot camp
Kristen: last year, and just like totally changed his career path, and he really likes it. But i'm just like man. I wish we took this like
in her twenties
brand: right,
Kristen: and
brand: and we can write to our website and see what there is. We're wake up,
brand: open It's like a tab.
brand: Hey, Job,
brand: the jail
brand: that's home.
brand: Go to sleep,
brand: see that it browses up and down if I do it like to get back to the top of the page.
brand: That was really easy sailing there.
brand: I'm sorry
brand: I would say I was going to be
brand: accessible to Ted
Kristen: here. Um, Kate said that if there isn't any bad experiences on on the site, is there something that you want to talk about that is really hard to do using dragon like that you've noticed on other sites without saying any names of companies or anything.
brand: Ah,
Kristen: i'm exactly trying. I am,
brand: which has a field again the first same field, because sometimes I can't dictate right into a.
I feel
brand: i'll play
brand: um
brand: wake up.
brand: It's like the first time
brand: serial.
brand: I just like that at work. It's fine it. They arrange it, but other times it like It's
brand: Here's the website direct to the date.
brand: It's whoever it like. I
it's a messaging. So I work with someone.
brand: I had to open up a separate box first. Be sure it that's like.
Wake up!
brand: Open the t-shirt box,
brand: Jackson,
brand: the transfer
brand: get the same
brand: so it just transferred to it.
brand: Um!
brand: I have the cursor in the right spot. It's why it's well, one word there, but anyway, it's a
brand: is there fields,
brand: if it does it work uh
Kristen: and sometimes with websites. A.
brand: I can't like him
brand: with the jet there with you.
brand: It's
brand: the it'll collapse. I'll be here. It
brand: I apologize for it. From there we had to take it out of the room.
Um,
brand: yeah, it didn't happen with this one, but as soon as I get to it,
brand: jet, that's where you put the mouse
brand: if you're with the best Again
brand: the the chapter meeting collapses.
brand: I don't know if you ever experienced that with.
brand: When you're using a bounce, if you move it away,
kill,
brand: disappear, I do.
Kristen: Yeah, that's that. Seems to be a lot of uh.
Kristen: It's definitely a poppy of mine
like everyone I've talked to a lot of people that use like screen magnifier tools are saying the same thing
Kristen: in this.
Kristen: Any of the hover drop-down menus, or just
Kristen: so go.
Kristen: It's a
Kristen: that's what it's called. Okay,
brand: How about that? Yeah,
Kristen: Yeah, yeah. I immediately told my partner so he could tell his whole development team at the company.
Kristen: Nobody likes that
other than that. It's very I read,
brand: I I've learned how to get around blind things here with the
brand: the commands is always the first option to just speak it,
brand: Tab. They are good tab road
brand: um,
brand: and use the mouse, for it is my assumption
Kristen: right. Do you want to show what that looks like on
brand: Wake up!
Kristen: That's good.
brand: Saved you
brand: to the sleep
brand: right there, Right? Okay,
What is it that they be?
Kristen: But that's it. It's a
Kristen: just a little extra step you have to take.
brand: Sometimes it's more technical to me because the mouse grid may take a few seconds to
brand: to come up, or it's a little slower
Kristen: right. Does it ever? Um, I was thinking about like
Kristen: like the touch kind of size, or like the focus size of buttons and things like that.
Kristen: Is there times when you like, think one of the numbers is going to actually activate it, and then it actually doesn't, and you have to keep trying.
Kristen: It's a
brand: to redo it. Um!
brand: That's that's my best. That's that's all i'll be
too fast, and
Kristen: I was wondering about that because on I was doing a bunch of mobile app testing the other day, and I kept getting all these like warnings, for, like the touch spots being too small. So there's like a little drop down menu button,
Kristen: and the area that you could actually click on. It was super small, and it should have been a lot bigger, and that would just let people like actually
Kristen: tap it usually easier and not directly on the thing
brand: i'm trying to like first. I'd be very small at this page. I don't see anything that's small, but
brand: you know you mean sometimes it's very hard to focus right on this, but but it gets pretty precise Where? How small I can get. You know
brand: me show you like, if I wanted to go to,
because you're a disabled pathways.
Kristen: I just about to click on the F. I'll show you how. Wake up.
brand: That's great.
brand: Five, one,
brand: two, for
brand: six.
brand: There is a score at it.
brand: Go to sleep.
brand: So yeah, it's a
brand: that I've had the experience of,
brand: you see,
brand: with those speech recognition this past couple of weeks,
brand: because table was all right. That's able to
brand: the jacket wasn't working, and
brand: that's why I I missed a lot. Because where those versions
brand: Hello, it's the old school.
brand: It it doesn't work at all well, especially with the
Kristen: trying to drag something or but it doesn't let you do that. You can't drag anything right-click or left-click.
brand: Um, Yeah, it doesn't work. Well,
Kristen: it's a
brand: so I I missed it when it wasn't working.
It's like, I work you good.
Kristen: Yeah, Does that
Kristen: happen often?
brand: That was the first time, but
it's a place of my years. I've been using it. Um!
brand: I had some do it when there's eleven. I'm not sure why they're grated. But with those Ted
brand: as a
brand: it works up there there.
Kristen: Oh, that's good. Hmm.
Kristen: It's just to do it, though
Kristen: it is there. What we got you there.
Kristen: Wow! Well, i'm glad you got it fixed, so most of them
Kristen: I don't.
Kristen: I don't know if there's anything else we have to really go through. But
Kristen: is there anything else like on
Kristen: this app, or the website that are
Kristen: that you've noticed That's maybe maybe it's It's that's my great. I
brand: I can get to the air
brand: like if there's a time request. But it gets you a lot quicker now. They okay.
brand: It was the best-grade work like I used to.
brand: So it was a big plus,
Kristen: please.
Kristen: That's good.
Kristen: It's
Kristen: yeah, I don't. I don't think I have there anything else. But
Kristen: so I don't.
Kristen: I don't know it
Kristen: to do. We can. We can chat for a half hour. I don't know
Kristen: I can give you half hour of your day back,
Kristen: whatever you want
brand: Where? Where you you you
Kristen: I'm in uh Peterborough actually, which is uh
Kristen: two hours north.
Kristen: Ooh, don't try
if
Kristen: yeah. Northeast of Toronto.
Kristen: Where are you? At It's that direction, my good
brand: uh! I will take it.
Oh, cool!
Kristen: What's it like in Connecticut? I've never been.
brand: Um.
brand: I don't know it's whatever I used up here. They hit your rural areas and
brand: do I get to the city? I said that far.
brand: I mean It's a lot like I've been to a couple of times. It's very.
Kristen: It is the air quality back. Yeah,
Yeah.
brand: But uh,
brand: and we have all four seasons here, and
brand: I would. I prefer going south from. I go down the floor. I eventually someday, but
Kristen: me, too.
Kristen: I'm kind of dreading the winter here. I hate it so much like I just I'm not great with the cold.
Kristen: Yeah, yeah. I've lived here my whole life. I try to travel as much as I can, but I
Kristen: I've been to Florida a few times for just kind of family trips or
Kristen: a week here and there, and it's it's so nice like just
Kristen: beautiful weather. This is the winter. Right?
Kristen: Yeah,
Kristen: yeah, there's a couple of years for my
Kristen: my parents and my aunt and uncle rented a house for like two or three weeks, and then I went down for a week and
Kristen: and spent the whole time there. And it was it was really nice. I also I don't know how much you talk to Canadians, but we have, like such limited like cool food options here.
Okay, compared to the States, like
Kristen: i'm a i'm a vegan and
Kristen: have some food allergies, so it's like,
brand: Let me let me have.
Kristen: Yeah, Pretty limited. So every time we go down there i'm just like, Oh, my God, look at all the things I can eat.
brand: Actually, seafood.
Kristen: No,
Kristen: yeah.
Kristen: But is it? Has it been really hot there, too?
Kristen: Yeah, it's been dry and hot? Yeah, we're here with the
Kristen: yeah. It's
brand: the
brand: wherever front is changing. So um
brand: where you get a lot cooler coming from today
Kristen: the day of September.
brand: That's a day for that.
brand: Is this really a cool area
Kristen: we we kind of are at night, but today i'm just looking at the temperature because it was extremely hot earlier. I think it cooled down because we had a. We had a thunderstorm today,
Kristen: but yesterday it was like
Kristen: it was like thirty Feels like thirty, seven, or something, Celsius. So it's like
Kristen: is is toasty.
brand: Yeah,
Kristen: Yeah,
brand: that's a very right. That's how we use here.
Kristen M: Yeah, I'm: not sure what it is in Fahrenheit, but
it's hot.
Kristen: I like,
Kristen: Yeah, it's. It's like ninety two degrees. Feels like a hundred degrees.
Kristen: Yeah, and it's been like that all summer, like I used to um. We have a little sitting area at the back of my place, with a barbecue and stuff on it, and
Kristen: I used to sit out there and do work and bring my laptop out. But I haven't done that at all this summer, because it's just been.
Kristen: It's just here. That's how usual is it for?
Kristen: Yeah, it's been getting a little scary the last few years. To be honest, it just keeps getting
Kristen: hotter and more humid. So i'm kind of like
Kristen: this isn't like this when I was a kid
brand: there.
Kristen: Yeah, it's weirdly the the place that i'm living in now is. It's a kind of medium-sized city for Canada, like probably pretty small
Kristen: by like American standards. But it's a
Kristen: yeah there's this. There's not a lot going on here
Kristen: except for summer tourism like It's very much like
Kristen: there's like there's canoeing. There's a lot of
Kristen: summer tourist stuff happening, and then,
Kristen: as soon as that's over, it's just kind of ghost town.
Kristen: There we there's a really slow Yeah, I watched that
brand: that podcast. But um,
brand: Youtube videos from people from Canada, because I'm at the plants. So I I
the it's that
Kristen: I have different things to say. Yeah,
Kristen: uh, yeah, Every time I I think of it all as a nice
Kristen: plants that I bought the summer, and how like for outside just nice flowers and stuff, and
and thinking about. If we lived in a warmer place these would just be.
Kristen: They would be okay, like year round. We could enjoy the beautiful flowers. But
Kristen: maybe some day
brand: are you with the secular? So
Kristen: I I want to be. I have had a really bad track record with her.
Kristen: Do you have any?
brand: Yeah, It's about two years ago
brand: they get to, and the
brand: I was. I'm just so addicted
brand: every day. You see whether it's story or I tried something different.
Kristen: Right? What's your favorite plant that you have?
brand: I like the Clinton's a lot to do like the pair plants and stuff like that.
Kristen: Me?
Yeah, they have so many cool leaves like so many different kinds.
brand: Yeah, so i'm sorry. These I know that,
brand: and
brand: I like how they're so colorful.
brand: I just agreed. Do you feel It's a
brand: I don't have to keep it
brand: in the light all the time you are. You deserve
brand: very much to play. You can put anywhere in the house.
Kristen: Yeah, yeah, they're nice. I'll take you into my kitchen and show you my plants with you.
Kristen: Oh, yeah, Cool here. That's usually we have. We have some cats, so we have to keep all of our plants
up.
Kristen: But, uh, I do have
Kristen: quite a ceiling here.
Kristen: Let me know. Yeah, look at my idea. If I check it, the screen bigger,
brand: It's like everybody's there,
brand: but three,
brand: five, three,
brand: six, three,
brand: though I didn't do it.
brand: Let's move down
brand: basically
brand: Do you know how I get the screen back up again.
Kristen: Um,
Kristen: not sure. You can really stop screen sharing.
Kristen: If we're done, we can just chat
brand: that one
brand: good to see.
Kristen: Yes, I worked. I got a bunch of a lot of pathos like buying guys going on.
brand: Is that what it is? It's got this here? Is that what it is? The theipping Pat. No,
Kristen: that is a a nerve plant like a fatonia. But oh, yeah, it's yeah, it's been. I don't know what's going on, but it's kind of like
Kristen: It's fine, but it's getting like more scraggly looking. So
Kristen: I've got a couple little.
The sky is here,
brand: There you go.
brand: I won't.
brand: I'll propagate you going out there.
Kristen: Yeah,
Kristen: yeah, I broke a couple of people. It's so easy to propagate.
Kristen: So easy It's great, And then in the bathroom. I've got this,
Kristen: So that's a nice
Kristen: yeah.
brand: I want to withdraw my bathroom because
Kristen: it's It's really nice. This one doesn't work. What is it? Where the builder?
brand: What is it is that What's here?
Kristen: This Which one? This one?
brand: It was a bill.
Kristen: Yeah, it's a tetrasperma. I don't remember the full name of it, but it's it's like a monster. It's got
Kristen: the leaves of the demonstrations and stuff in it, but it's it's like shot right up.
brand: Yes,
Kristen: yeah, it's it. It loves it to me, I guess, for the
Kristen: yeah. Yeah, it's getting a lot of humidity in here, and this is a peculiar plant that I've had.
Kristen: Uh, I don't know how long a long time this has like kind of fuzzy,
Kristen: fuzzy leaves, and it smells.
Kristen: It's really strong, like the truly.
Kristen: But that plan is really funny, because
Kristen: it's.
Kristen: I don't know I had a really bad time like killing a lot of plants
Kristen: over the years, as I learned how to take care of them, and
Kristen: and that one as soon as it needs water. It just looks like It's completely dead. Like all of the leaves
Kristen: I completely droop, and I can just dump like tons and tons of water in it.
Kristen: Never, never root brought, never any problems.
Kristen: It just about this back.
Kristen: Yeah. So I I don't know, like I was really bad with over watering stuff for a while, and that one just just dump water, and then
Kristen: it seems to love it. So
brand: there we go,
brand: like a big problem with the
Kristen: the focus. That's yeah, everything. I try It's not working.
Kristen: Yeah, that's we have them here, too. And I just don't.
Kristen: I don't know what to do about them anymore.
Kristen: They are
Kristen: at least they're not like bites or anything like that. You know. It's
brand: it's not our phone to your play, I don't think.
Kristen: No, I think they're They're not harmful. They're just
Kristen: what else? What else are you into beside the plants,
brand: sports and stuff like that, you know. I like, uh American football is coming up. So i'm excited about that.
Kristen: There you go,
brand: and i'm just like being out there to do it most of the time.
brand: It'll just be a touch of nature.
brand: Have a dog, so we like to go out walks and stuff. We just go around the neighborhood.
brand: He's got this stuff. Okay,
brand: that's also what kind of see
Kristen M: It's A: i'm ready to Alex. It looks like a little fox.
Kristen: I love that
Kristen: that's really cute.
Kristen: Yeah, The The pandemic time kind of made me
Kristen: want to get a dog because I kept inviting friends who have dogs over to
Kristen: in our yard, just because that's like outside is better than inside. Hang out so
Kristen: a pit.
Kristen: But we have three cats, and our apartment's pretty small, so I don't think it's.
Kristen: It's not going to actually. I can't have cats, because
brand: I like
Kristen: my eyes of like a very. It's a good. I'm allergic to them. So
Kristen: yeah, it's too bad.
Kristen: Do you give them a guys?
Kristen: Yeah, My partner used to be allergic to them, too. And then,
Kristen: because all like she's just went away eventually. Oh, really, I guess.
Kristen: Yeah, he was exposed. Exposed himself enough that
it's like it.
Kristen: That's a good.
Kristen: It's pretty lucky, because I don't know if I would have
it doesn't deliver them over the cat.
brand: Yeah, other than that, I um.
Kristen: I just enjoyed me on the computer, too, browsing around Youtube and stuff like that, you know,
Kristen: getting into Youtube holes.
brand: Yeah,
Kristen: Have you ever said blocking anything?
Kristen: No,
Kristen: have you?
I'm: more of a consumer.
Kristen: Yeah,
Kristen: Always behind the camera, taking pictures of things. And
Kristen: yeah, he is not not so much in front.
brand: How long is it You're a speech to you.
brand: I like. How far is it
Kristen: sorry
brand: like? How far is it to your speech to you?
brand: The ocean?
Kristen: It's? Ah,
Kristen: the ocean pretty far
have to go to like
Kristen: a different province, or it's maybe even closer to go to the States. But we're on. I'm about an hour and a half north of Lake Ontario shore,
Kristen: but where I grew up was actually right along the shoreline. So I grew up with
Kristen: like Ontario, just right in front of my parents place. So
Kristen: that was really nice. I do miss uh
Kristen: thinking of like I do at the Great Lakes I just mentioned to be that day about
brand: how they were formed, and stuff was really interesting. It used to be a saltwire.
Kristen: Yeah, it used to be like a
brand: You see. Yeah,
Kristen: wow, that's cool I didn't know about before the uh
brand: potential ships.
brand: It was like located in the
brand: We're like they're they're creator
Kristen: really really fresh out. Yeah,
Kristen: my,
Kristen: that's so cool. You're gonna look that up later.
brand: How the great links are, for
Kristen: I love you. That I love
brand: explains about um
brand: the floor of the of the Great Lakes
brand: that all by two, just three of them.
brand: Um!
brand: They
brand: I have a plate. I do you to take a so where plate it just hearted it.
brand: I do need that. They do a lot of salt lighting.
brand: It's from It's remember where it used to be. The saltwire dried up.
Kristen: What? Yes,
Kristen: that's so cool.
brand: It's really weird. I was surprised.
Kristen: Yeah, I had no idea.
I'm gonna watch that later.
Kristen: I I read the the criteria once in
I was so raised that it looked like the ocean.
brand: It's so huge
Kristen: it's really big like when, if i'm at my Parents' place and we look out, used to be able to see it. I don't think you can really see it much anymore because of pollution and smog and stuff. But we could see New York State
Kristen: really across the water, because it's like not actually that far from the border, like where I grew up it's like
Kristen: maybe a forty-five minutes.
Kristen: Um! It comes out in your
Kristen: I was the closest town like Watertown.
brand: Okay, Yeah, there's a lot of my parents to go. So really up there.
Kristen: Oh, okay,
Kristen: cool. Yeah. So yeah, my family's from like that kind of Kingston
Kristen: area in Canada. So it's like
Kristen: we used to go to Watertown and Syracuse fairly often just for
Kristen: doing something
Kristen: is. And
brand: did you guys so really
Kristen: pardon, Did you ever do so, Billy?
Kristen: Snowmobiling? Yes, actually, when when I was a kid, my Dad had
Kristen: two. We used to take them out of it.
Kristen: Then he flipped it and got hurt, and we sold them,
brand: and that's the place to do it. It's beautiful up there the
brand: the winter without the so they got.
Kristen: Yeah, that's like kind of the only thing I do like about the winter is just. It is nice. It's very pretty, and if you're into any kind of winter sports it's
Kristen: it's fine. I just don't. I don't appreciate the the sidewalks here are really bad, like
Kristen: I'm sure
Kristen: it's super poorly maintained, and they kind of leave it up to everybody to just take care of their own
Kristen: sidewalk section instead of the city removing the snow. So
Kristen: we usually end up throwing salt down like half the block, because
Kristen: I don't want people to fall like it's just
Kristen: here. If if you don't take care of yourself, you get five.
Kristen: You're supposed to, but
Kristen: I don't know if I've ever seen that happen
Kristen: my work.
Kristen: Well, i'm looking forward to the fall, though it should be
Kristen: nicer nicer weather and
Kristen: like when the trees change,
Kristen: don't be so humid.
Kristen: Yeah, your your name is Christie. Right?
Kristen: I hope we get to.
Kristen: Yeah. Me, too.
Kristen: Yeah, thanks. This has been great. This is like
Kristen: a great first interview. Nice to chat.
Kristen: Do you have anything else lined up
Kristen: every day, though it's been really slow last. But it was a
brand: I had like two or three interviews the whole month.
Kristen: Yeah. So it was a I'm hoping it was just because
brand: the different companies are on vacation or whatever.
Kristen: Yeah, I think the end of summer is kind of weird time for people a lot of people just take off for like the entire month.
Kristen: Yeah, I'm going to Toronto on Friday, actually to meet with Kate and Nick
Kristen: for the first time I went to school with Nick. I don't know if you have met him before,
brand: I think we did have an interview together, I guess.
Kristen: Ah, yeah,
Kristen: yeah, We went to. We did an online graduate program together in accessible media production. And
Kristen: so we've known each other for like two years or something, but we've never actually met in real life. So
Kristen: there is one.
Kristen: Yeah. So yeah, it'll be fun.
Kristen: Have not been to the city much since the the pandemic.
brand: I'm A.
brand: Since I was a kid that I would.
brand: I really like to go back.
brand: They have the underground say like,
brand: Or is that what you're
Kristen: Um,
Kristen: I don't know what Montreal has
Kristen: they have like a pretty good
Kristen: um,
Kristen: I don't know, like walkway connections and stuff underneath Toronto. Like through
Kristen: most of the downtown, you can just go
Kristen: underground and go through the subway system, which is pretty cool.
brand: Is it like?
brand: Well, this is like a
brand: underground ball, like a shopping mall and stuff
restaurants and things like that.
Kristen: So
brand: is that Toronto?
Kristen: It must be Toronto. Yeah,
Kristen: I've definitely been to some
Kristen: all like related kind of things like underground. But yeah,
Kristen: how how far a job is it?
Kristen: Um, It's like,
Kristen: Hmm. An hour and a half, two hours, maybe,
Kristen: which isn't too bad, except I can't drive, so I have to take the the
Kristen: to get a ride partway there, and then take a train into the city. So you
brand: there, there.
Kristen: So maybe a little bit longer of a commute for me.
brand: It takes about an hour to get the heart through for it, for where I am.
Kristen: Okay,
brand: about two hours at the bus,
Kristen: like Canada's so ridiculously big, especially Ontario, like my friends, just drove from Toronto to Portland, and it took them like three and a half days to get out of Ontario
Kristen: to our province like.
Kristen: But then, after that it seemed like It took just as long to get out of our province as it did to go through three other ones and then go across the border.
Kristen: Oh, yeah,
Kristen: I always wish that
Kristen: like if we lived in the States, it'd be cool because it just seems like you can go. You can travel two hours, and there's gonna be like a pretty cool city
Kristen: a lot of stuff to see
brand: unless you wear the
brand: the rest the right out there.
Kristen: Yeah,
brand: i'm surprised. You have a like an accident.
Kristen: I don't have an accent. Yeah, it's amazing. Oh, that's good.
Kristen: Yeah, I love it.
Kristen: That's really funny, because my Ah, one of my friends is from upstate New York, and she's always making fun of our Canadian accents, even though I don't think they're that much different than
brand: no, I don't. I don't think. Yeah, though
Kristen: I I appreciate it.
Kristen: We're a brid like Manitoba area. They think they're a little thicker accents, and of course, come back. You have the French accents
Kristen: here.
Kristen: I I love an East Coast maritime accent with Newfoundland accent.
Kristen: Yes, yes, it's a good.
Kristen: It's funny.
brand: I love the southern accent like that
Kristen: succulent a director of the area.
Kristen: Yeah, me, too. There's something very like soothing about it.
brand: It will be recorded.
Kristen: Yeah,
no, we're getting jealous.
Kristen: Yeah, I hope the clips that we got are good. I
Kristen: I think I'm going to be doing the editing together. So I think. Yeah,
Kristen: but yes, I have to remember about the recording.
Kristen: Um, Whoever watches the video can take a look at our nice plants and
Kristen: and think about access.
brand: Oh, it's a to be you?
Kristen: Yeah, you as well take care. And I hope that I get to work with you again.
brand: Yeah, I'm: Sure, we will.
Kristen: Yeah,
brand: welcome aboard.
Kristen: Thank you. I really try to.
brand: Okay
brand: here.
brand: That's great.
brand: Your virtue.
brand: Three six.
brand: That's what we've done.
brand: Pleasure.
brand: That's it.